so I wanted to create this short video
on things that don't break your fast I
keep getting this question over and over
and over again so instead of explaining
it I'm just going to create a video on
it
we have to realize is the ideal scene is
to only drink water when you're fasting
but really it's all about insulin it's
about keeping insulin low so if you were
to consume something that kept insulin
low it really is not going to interfere
with your the benefits of fasting okay
realize that carbs in protein stimulate
insulin so especially carbs and that
would include collagen okay
protein powder there's carbs in milk for
example there so like lactose milk sugar
there's also protein powder like whey
protein that has a real big effect on
insulin now there's a certain type of
carbohydrate that doesn't affect insulin
and that would be fiber
okay so fiber is not going to increase
insulin so let's say for example you're
eating celery or a little bit of a green
salad well the carbohydrate in that is
so low because it's mostly fiber it's
not going to have that much effect on
insulin so you're not going to have to
worry about it too much and the other
interesting thing is fat fat has the
least effect on insulin okay
I'm talking MCT oil butter coconut oil
whole cream now if you're doing
half-and-half for example doing half
milk and half cream there's a little
more carbohydrate in that so we may
affect insulin a little bit if you're
gonna put the half-and-half in your
coffee but if you want to just take it
to the next level use whole cream in
which there's like hardly any
carbohydrates and I mean maybe there's
like one carbohydrate but make its I
think it's actually less than one carb
and of course butter has less
carbohydrates than whole cream so butter
is just pure fat so you can actually
maybe put that in your coffee
now what about sugar alcohols the
alternative sweeteners right well you
have salat all which does affect insulin
a little bit so just take a little bit
if you want to take it it's low on the
scale but just take a little bit in your
coffee if you want to do that a wreath
rotol is like zero
fact an insulin multi-tool is really bad
don't even use that that's like I think
it's 58 on the glycemic index and then
you also have things like stevia monk
fruit which don't have any effect on
insulin at all so those are fine so you
can do sugar alcohols certain ones tea
is fine coffee is fine but of course if
you're drinking a lot of coffee and that
could be a problem because it could
start to stimulate cortisol which would
then increase insulin and by the way
stress does raise insulin to seven
degrees so that's nothing that you're
eating but just realize that that stress
can spike insulin a little bit if it's
too high and then we have supplements
supplements will not increase insulin so
don't worry about that
green powder usually has less than one
gram of carbohydrate and fiber or no
fiber it's a lot of chlorophyll and a
lot of concentrated green this is
totally fine I wouldn't worry about
green powder when you're doing insulin
so anyway I just wanted to create this
short video just to kind of cover the
basic points so you know how to do it
correctly thanks for watching
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it